did you know that one in eight women
will develop some kind of breast cancer
over the course of her lifetime and here
in nevada over two thousand women will
receive a breast cancer diagnosis j.c
talked with an expert from optimum care
breast care the sponsors of this segment
for information on how to treat this
disease and more
dr salamon thank you so much for joining
us today it's a pleasure to have you on
the show and today we're talking about
cancer prevention and breast cancer is
such an important issue with women how
common is this it's very common actually
the
one out of eight women would get breast
cancer in their lifetime in the us so
that puts your risk anywhere between 11
and 13 percent lifetime risk of breast
cancer and obviously it's the most
common cancer
amongst women how important is breast
cancer screening
it's extremely important because it's
important for us to
try to catch cancer at earlier stages
and treat it at earlier stages so that
that leads to better outcomes
then as far as early detection and early
screening
let's talk about some numbers or just
how important it is to catch things
early and survivable rate versus
catching it early versus catching it a
month or two after the fact
yeah
i mean breast cancer goes from stage
zero to stage four so if you can catch
things at stage zero or even stage one
you're looking at survival rates at five
and ten years that are well above ninety
percent
uh if you don't catch it early and your
cancer advances and stress to your lymph
nodes or other parts of your body that
number goes significantly lower in terms
of your overall survival you guys have
the survivor is it the survivorship
program tell us more about this
exactly so we have a high risk program
and a survivorship program a high-risk
program is for patients who are at
higher risk for breast cancer based on
several factors the most important of
which which is your family history
so if you have a strong family history
of breast cancer what we do is we
take into account all the risk factors
and calculate your lifetime risk of
breast cancer and based on that we might
offer you advanced screening so that's
that's called the high risk program then
there is the survivorship program it's
for patients who've already undergone
treatment for breast cancer
and we follow those patients closely
every six months for five years and then
usually annually after that and we
attend to their different needs not only
their cancer follow-up but their overall
wellness i think it's it's really
important for uh for every anyone who's
kind of viewing this interview to
kind of connect to their loved ones and
ask their mom or grandma or daughter if
they've
seen their primary care regarding
screening and that's that's what we
really need most of in vegas is
education
so that we can reach out to more people
and let them know what services are
available so that
we don't wait too long to catch things
at later stages
and we're always available here
obviously
you know and we even have mobile clinics
and mammogram units that you know that
go around the
city so there's so many offerings it's
just that we have to make sure our
patients and
are proactive in reaching out to us
thank you again to optim care breast
care for sponsoring that segment they
have several locations across southern
nevada so call
702-724-8787 for more information or
visit optum-cancer.com